IAN CHAKERES: I'm
Ian, and today we're
going to talk with you about
bringing your Kubernetes
to the cloud with Anthos.
But before we go into that, we'd
like to introduce ourselves.
I'm Ian Chakeres.
And I'm one of the
engineering leaders
working on Anthos and GKE.
And my team is
focused on making it
possible to manage and
monitor all your Kubernetes
infrastructure, whether it's
in the cloud or on prem.
I've been working with
Kubernetes for several years
now.
And I've lived through a
few of these different tech
transitions.
For example, from bare
metal to containers, as well
as from monoliths
to micro services.
And the thing that
brings excitement to me
is actually the velocity
that you can achieve
from these modern technologies.
And by allowing you to
focus on your business.
Matt.
MATTHEW DELIO: I'm Matt DeLio.
I'm one of the product managers
working on Anthos and GKE.
I've been on the team
for the past three years,
initially focusing on some
of our more infrastructure
pieces of Kubernetes.
But now I'm focused
on making it easier
to manage workloads and
clusters running anywhere.
AMR ABDELRAZIK: Hi everyone.
I'm Amr Abdelrazik.
I'm a product manager for
the Anthos [INAUDIBLE]..
I focus on [INAUDIBLE].
I've been working in this
space for many years.
I've worked on Kubernetes,
Anthos, [INAUDIBLE]..
But I've also been a customer
for many, many years, which
helps me understand where
all you guys are coming from.
Thank you for coming.
And we have an exciting
program for you.
So I'm going to let Matt.
MATTHEW DELIO: Sure, thank you.
Here's our agenda for
the next 30 minutes.
We're going to start
out by exploring
the problem space
a little bit more
and the challenges
you're facing.
Next, we're going
to look into how
Anthos is uniquely
positioned to help
you address these challenges.
And then finally, we're going
to have a deep dive on one
of the solutions we're providing
in Anthos for observerability
and management.
So let's get started.
I wanted to spend a few
minutes really looking
at the challenges, kind of
recapping a little bit of what
Aparna said about the
challenges that you're facing,
and how containers, Kubernetes,
and ultimately Anthos can help
you address these challenges.
So as Aparna mentioned
a few moments ago,
as companies are leaning
more and more on your IT
organization to
deliver solutions
that help them adapt quickly to
changes in the market, consumer
demand, and also to create
competitive advantage.
In addition-- and we'll
explore this later.
--you're being asked to run
these solutions in multitudes
of environments, both in
cloud and on premises,
all while maintaining
your initial focus, which
is reducing risk and cost.
This is a tough challenge,
but it's not impossible.
Containerization can help
your developers and operators
be more productive.
And Kubernetes
coupled with Anthos
can help you run
efficiently wherever
you need to be running.
So as you probably
know, containers
are a necessary building block.
That's why we're all here in
San Diego this week for sure.
But they're really important
to make your teams more agile.
In a nutshell,
containers are easier
to manage than traditional
solutions, be it bare metal
or VM based.
For example, when you need to
make a change to a production
application, there's
no need to patch
a binary on a VM or a machine.
Just toss out the old container
and replace it with a new one.
When operating
containers, there's
less infrastructure to manage,
patch, and otherwise maintain.
Another major benefit is
the containers give you
reproducible and
consistent artifacts
throughout your dev, test, and
production deployment stages.
This makes it far easier and
faster to develop and debug
your workloads.
The net result is that
developers and operators
can focus more on the
development instead of managing
and patching infrastructure.
But you may be thinking
to yourself containers
by themselves are not enough.
You need tooling to manage
and run these container based
applications.
Kubernetes is that tooling.
Now, one of the key
features of Kubernetes
is that it provides an
abstraction from the underlying
infrastructure.
This is particularly useful,
given the challenges and goals
we've discussed up till now.
With Kubernetes, your
developers and service operators
can learn a common set of
tooling, APIs, et cetera,
and apply them anywhere
Kubernetes runs.
Now that we know that
containers and Kubernetes help
us run workflows anywhere,
why would we need to?
Here are some of the top hybrid
and multi-cloud use cases
you've told us about.
The first one on
the top left here
is invoking legacy dependencies.
While you can move certain
workloads to cloud,
there will always be some on
premises services that either
have not or cannot
be moved to cloud.
In the middle on the top
is service availability.
We hear all the
time that in order
to achieve your particular
latency and availability
requirements, you need to
deploy your application
across multiple regions
and serve traffic to them.
Another one we hear
a lot, especially
in the multi-cloud context,
is developer choice.
It's important to give your
teams access to the preferred
manage services, which
will reduce their friction
and help them move
a lot more quickly.
And that brings us to data
locality and regulation
on the bottom left there.
Regulatory requirements
often come up
where you're required
to keep your data
and compute in specific
regions throughout the world.
This can be on premises.
It could be in multiple clouds.
It could be anywhere.
Another one that's
kind of emerging--
in the bottom of the last
two are sort of emerging.
But local execution
comes up a lot,
where is providing mission
critical applications
to local, often on
premises environments.
The examples we have here,
warehouses, branches,
even factories.
And you want to do
this in a way that
allows you to build
manage and maintain
these applications using modern
tooling driven from cloud.
And finally, in the bottom
right we've got edge computing.
It's very similar
to local execution,
but it's more constrained.
You've got more remote
connectivity problems.
And you've got non-traditional
compute environments.
So we saw how adopting
containers and Kubernetes
help improve velocity,
increase portability.
We saw many reasons
why you would
want to run workloads anywhere.
But now.
How do you do this
efficiently and effectively
across all of these
different environments?
And that's why we built Anthos.
It's a software stack that uses
Kubernetes as its foundation
and provides through additional
layers, which Amr will show us
in a minute,
consistency, security,
and management capabilities,
which in turn accelerates
your developer velocity.
To tell you more about
those and how it does this,
I'll now turn it over to Amr.
AMR ABDELRAZIK: Thanks.
MATTHEW DELIO: Thanks.
AMR ABDELRAZIK: Thanks, Matt.
MATTHEW DELIO: Sure.
AMR ABDELRAZIK: So we're going
to cover a little bit of--
can you guys hear me OK?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
AMR ABDELRAZIK: Thank you.
We're going to cover a
little bit of an overview.
Aparna covered some of that.
So we're going to walk
through some of these quickly.
But again, the idea
is you look at Anthos
as the software
stack that enables
you to do the operations,
the management of, of course,
all your apps.
This is what we're going
to talk about in this talk.
A little bit focus
on the infrastructure
and also the managed operation.
Aparna covered this.
We are talking about how
Anthoss is a software based
stack with an open software and
abstracting the infrastructure
way.
But when you look at
Anthos deployment option,
I think that's kind of where
we really differentiate is.
We've looked at where a
lot of our customers are.
And the reality is, you
customers are running things
everywhere, from
Google Cloud platforms,
from vSphere, from
some of the other cloud
providers, BareMetal,
or even some of you
have your own
communities cluster.
And this was taken
in conservation
as we were building Anthos and
how it can fit and actually
help you run across all
of these environments.
So kind of coming to you as
a customer where you are,
instead of trying to bring you
and force you to a specific
place where you want to run.
When I look at the components
of Anthos and how it fits,
this is how I like to
mentally think about it.
The first box on the bottom,
you have Anthos Migrate.
And you can bring new
applications to Anthos,
kind of have some
kind of greenfield.
But also as Aparna
mentioned, there
is a lot of existing
applications
that you have to
accommodate to you.
You would love to
migrate to have to use
some of those capabilities.
So Migrate, which we went to GA
I think this week or last week,
helps you a lot with that.
The next part, I have my app.
I want to run it somewhere.
Where do I run it?
And this is where we
give you some options.
This is where we try to give
you some options, again,
between GKE on the cloud,
between Anthos GKE deployed
on BareMetal, and between
Anthos GKE deployed on some
of the other cloud providers.
So the next part is, I've
got all of these clusters.
I want to manage them together.
What do I do?
And this is where
hub and connect,
which Ian's going to talk
about more in detail comes in.
I'll say OK, how can
I have this visibility
and centralized visibility
across all of these clusters
and manage my applications?
So OK, I got my
clusters up running.
I got my applications
up running.
I can see them all.
What do I do next?
You might want to make sure
that all of these clusters
are configured correctly
and to same standards
you have in enterprise.
And this is where Anthos
conflict management comes in--
making sure that all your
clusters are consistent,
making sure that all
the configuration are
consistent across
any cloud provider.
You've got your
clusters up and running.
applications up running.
Everything is OK.
Now I want to get this
second level of visibility
into how my
applications are run.
I want to get this deep dive
into my SLO, my performance.
And this is where Anthos
Service Mesh comes in.
Anthos Service Mesh adds this
additional layer of visibility,
add this additional layer of
control on the infrastructure
layer by using Istio
to give you that
is almost like x-ray like
visibility across all
of your apps to see exactly
where is the leniency, which
apps are talking to each
other, which ones are affecting
the performance of
your application, which
is specifically critical as
you move to micro services.
So you got your
service mesh now.
What do I do?
Let's get more application.
And this is where capabilities
such as Cloud Run, GCP
marketplace comes in.
And more and more
applications are
going to be running from
Google and some other partners
to help you run all
of these applications.
As you look at
this, this actually
helps you look at your
application infrastructure,
where you are in the
journey, and get with you
and introduce the existing
component, whatever
component you need to manage
where you are in your journey.
Focusing a little
bit about Anthos GKE.
GKE is kind of the
foundation of a lot of this.
GKE is our Kubernetes
distribution.
It runs the first
generation of that,
as our partner mentioned,
five years ago.
Came in live on GCP.
And it's one of the most widely
regarded, widely respected
Kubernetes platform.
But the idea is you
don't have to think
about a lot of
these technologies.
This is like a production
grade applications.
You got access to
all the services.
You can easily
start, easy upgrade,
all of these things
that shouldn't
take you a lot of
time, because you
want to make sure that you
are focusing on your business
and focusing your application.
But then this comes
in GKE Anthos GKE
on prem, which is you've got
a turnkey production grade
[INAUDIBLE] Kubernetes.
You've got running,
got the best practices,
you've got access to
Container services on GCP.
Again, easy upgrade path.
A lot of the capabilities that
you want to get from the cloud.
A lot of customers
came to us and say,
hey, I would love to have this
running on my infrastructure.
I have this existing
SAP application.
I have this existing other
applications that I cannot
move.
And I need this keeping all
of these capabilities and all
the experience that I'm
used to on the cloud.
So this is where Anthos GKE
on prem kind of comes in.
The next part of that
we're going to talk about,
I'm going to hand it
over to Ian to talk
about that layer
of observability
and the layer of management,
and having this visibility
across these applications.
So with that, I'll
hand it over to Ian.
IAN CHAKERES: I'm pretty lucky
with the microphones today.
Matt has given a
bit of an overview
for why customers
are coming to Anthos
and what you can
get from Anthos.
And then Amr did a
bit of a deep dive
into several of the components.
And I'm going to
really dive deeper
into the technology and the
multi-cluster observability
and management features.
I'm going to start by
talking about connecting
your clusters to Google with
their single pane of glass.
And I'll then give some demos.
Just to start with some
of the terminology here,
you've got Kubernetes clusters.
They can be on GCP.
They can be on prem.
They can be on other clouds.
And the first step is to
register those clusters
with Google's control
plane and the GKE hub.
Those clusters get
connected to GCP
by installing a connect agent.
And then you can log in
and interact and view
the workloads in those clusters.
We have an amazing UI for GKE.
And we've extended that to
Kubernetes clusters anywhere.
With this single
plane of glass, you
can interact with all your
GKE clusters, as well as
GKE on prem clusters, which
are actually connected
when they are created.
Via this single
pane of glass, you
can monitor and
manage your workloads
no matter where they are.
You can dig into the
cluster resources
and actually see what the
version of the cluster
is, how many nodes
are in that cluster,
what the CPO and memory are.
You can actually
view and inspect
all the different workloads
that are running in there,
and whether they are
healthy, or whether they
might have a problem.
The GKE UI also provides
additional context
and surfaces
relevant information.
For example, if there is an
error, if there is a problem
it'll raise those
alerts or warnings
and make them really
easy and actionable.
And if you have
sufficient permissions,
you can also manipulate
resources directly from the UI.
For example, scaling
up a deployment
or changing the version
of an application.
So the cloud console
really provides
a consistent UI
for your operators
and your developers across
clouds and across clusters.
Now I'm going to talk
about how you connect
your clusters to Google.
To connect your
clusters, you run
a agent that runs in your
cluster and connects to Google.
Looking at the diagram here,
in the bottom right-hand side
this is your
infrastructure and this
is your Kubernetes clusters.
And on the top, this is
GCP and Google Cloud.
And so you can see, we've got
a few different keys and locks
here.
These relate to different
security operations
that are happening.
I'm going to first talk
about installing the agent.
So you see that there's a lock
and a key with the GCP Cloud
logo.
So you install that agent.
And you use GCP Service
account for the authentication
and authorization.
And a encrypted connection
gets formed to Google
from that agent, connecting
your cluster to Google.
If for any reason the
agent gets disconnected,
it will periodically
attempt to reconnect.
When you visit the cloud
console after you've
connected a cluster--
this is in the upper
left-hand corner there.
You can see there's a little
key and the Kubernetes icon.
This is actually you
logging in as you.
And in the bottom left is
the API server with the lock.
And this is where
role-based access controls
that are set by you and your
administrators come into play.
So actually, depending on
what your privileges are
when you log in, you
can do different things
from the cloud console.
And administrators
can essentially
scope permissions
to least privilege
to ensure that you can only do
the things that you need to be
able to do in that cluster.
Now that I've told you
about how to securely log
into your clusters and
interact with them,
we're going to go ahead
and move over to the demos.
So in the first demo
I'm going to talk
about deploying
the connect agent
and registering your
cluster, then logging in
and show you a little bit
about the cloud console.
So I have a Kubernetes
cluster here.
It's just a single
node kind cluster,
which is Kubernetes and Docker.
And it's 115.
You can see I have
the customer there.
It has a few small
number of pods running
and a few deployments.
And we go to the
cloud console here,
we can see we have a number of
different Kubernetes clusters
already in this project.
We've got GK clusters, as well
as clusters from other clouds.
And we're going to
register this cluster,
and then log in and
interact with it.
So I'm hitting the
register button.
I'm just going to
call it My Cluster.
And we are here in San Diego.
And it's a Kubernetes
and Docker cluster.
And I'm going to go ahead
and generate the registration
command.
So what you can
see in the bottom
there is actually certain
things are waiting to happen.
And there's a
particular command here
that takes information
about the cluster,
so that it can deploy the agent.
For example, a cluster
config and a kubeconfig path,
as well as a local key file.
That local key file is
the GCP service account
that I talked about for
connecting the agent back
to cloud.
So you can see here, I have the
GCP service account right here.
I'm just going to go ahead--
I already have the command
here with all that information.
So what this command
is going to do
is actually install the agent
and form the connection back
to Google.
And what we should see
is after a few moments,
the related agent will get
deployed in the cluster.
And we'll see updates
here in the background.
Let's see.
So now it's deployed the agent.
Now let's hope the--
we see the two green dots.
What this means
is now the cluster
has registered and gotten
connected to Google.
Now you can set
some more labels,
but I'm just going
to go ahead and skip
adding more labels to it.
And now what you can
see is that in addition
to the other clusters that I
had, I now have my cluster.
Now as I mentioned, once
you've registered your cluster
you actually have to log in.
And you'll have to log
in with your credentials.
So for this demo, I've actually
setup a Kubernetes service
account granting
me cluster admin,
just so I can do all the
different types of operations
that I want within this cluster.
So I'm going to paste the
key to go ahead and log in.
And now you can see
I've got the green dot.
I've got my clusters.
And now I also have it showing
me the cluster size, the CPU,
and the memory.
And we can actually
dive in deeper
and see what's going
on in that cluster.
You can see things like
the master version,
as well as the CPO and memory.
And you can see
the nodes as well.
So there's only one node
in this, as we showed here.
So we can see that node, and
we can see the different pods
as well that are running.
Let's go ahead.
Now we've connected
this cluster.
I mentioned that we had given
permission to actually deploy
workloads into this cluster.
So let's go ahead.
We're going to deploy an
application really quickly.
So I'm just going to use a
Hello World container here.
And I'm going to put it in--
I'm going to call
it Hello World.
And actually, I'm going to
deploy it into that cluster
that I just created.
Now what this is
doing is actually
going through the connection
and actually deploying
this particular application.
So what we should see is it will
declare the intent on the API
server.
And then the API server is
going to reconcile that intent
by creating the deployment
and spinning up all the pods.
So you can see there, it's
now created the Hello World
deployment.
And we can see that
everything is green.
And actually, we'll just hop
over here into the cluster
and look at the
deployments as well.
So there we are.
There's the Hello World
deployment, 3 and 3.
So in this demo, I showed you
how to deploy the connect agent
and get your cluster connected
to the cloud, how to log in,
and then how to interact
with that cluster via the UI.
Now I'm going to move on to
the second part of the demo.
So I'm going to talk about
monitoring, debugging,
and performing some updates.
And so this is going to show
you how the cloud console
really surfaces
information, helps
you debug and troubleshoot,
how with the appropriate
permissions you can actually
make changes and resolve them,
as well as some of the
other common operations
that you encounter.
We're going to start here.
We'll start on the
workloads page.
And what you can see is, you
can see there's a problem here.
And actually, let's
just filter it down.
And so you can see there's
a problem with this one
deployment here.
It says, does not meet
minimum availability.
So let's go ahead and dive into
that particular deployment.
Now right off the bat,
you can see that it's
surfacing the errors to me.
It's saying there's an
image pull back off error.
And I can actually click on
that and see specifically
what's going on.
And as you can see here,
if it's kind of small,
it looks like
somebody made a typo.
And so we actually--
this particular image
isn't available.
And so you can also see
that we want to have
one of this particular--
one of these pods running,
but it's not successful.
So let's go ahead.
We see that there's a typo.
So we'll go in here and edit.
And we're just going to
fix that particular error.
Now we're going to
save the changes.
And what this is
going to do is change
the image that is related to
this particular deployment.
And you can see that it starts
taking action immediately.
Now, we've resolved this
particular issue, the typo.
The image was
pulled successfully.
The deployment is green.
And the related pods
are also available.
So this is fantastic.
We had a problem.
It surfaced to us in
the UI immediately.
And we were able to
resolve it quickly.
Now, we know that
later today there's
going to be a lot
of traffic load
for this particular application.
So let's go through a few of
the common scenarios there.
The first thing
we'd like to do is--
we only have one replica,
which doesn't really give us
much redundancy or much scale.
So the first thing let's
do is let's go ahead
and scale this application up.
So we're just going to
give it five replicas.
What's going to happen when I
click this button is actually,
it's going to say,
instead of just one
pod for this deployment, I want
five pods for this deployment.
And then it's going to
spin up all those pods.
We'll likely catch it here
when it's starting up.
So you can see, we wanted
five and it started
creating the other ones.
Let's hit refresh.
All right, so now
we've got five replicas
running of Hello World.
And we can see that all the
pods associated with this
are running.
Now this is great.
Via the UI, a few clicks, we
just scaled up our application.
But you know how it is.
As soon as you think you're
all set, there's a problem
or there's some new feature
you want to roll out.
So what we're
going to do next is
we're actually going
to roll out an update
to this particular deployment.
I'm just going to
leave three seconds
in between as the
different pods spin up.
And we're going to move
it from 1.0 to 2.0.
And what should happen
here is at no time
should we have less
than five pods running.
And actually, what
it's going to do
is it's going to
roll the updates.
So it'll spin up a 2.0 pod
and shut down a 1.0 pod.
And then spin up another
2.0, and shut down a 1.0,
so that we always have at
least five replicas running
at any one point of time.
We're rolling out the updates,
and you see that-- actually, we
had those five running.
And we start getting
some more running,
because we're seeing this
rolling state as some spin up
and some shut down from
the old version, 1.0,
to the new version.
You can see the deployment
is gone, but some of the pods
are still running.
It's going to take
another few more
seconds before the old
pods get shut down.
Some of them are starting
to shut down there.
All right, so now
we've done the update.
This particular deployment has
five of the new pods running.
And we've updated
the application.
So that's the second demo.
And now we're going to
switch back to the slides.
Can you switch us back
to the slides, please?
Thank you.
All right, so Matt talked
a bit about the velocity,
as well as where people
have their infrastructure
and need to be running.
And then Amr dug into Anthos
and really an overview of many
of the different components.
And then I went through
and actually showed you
a demo about connecting
your clusters to Google,
as well as
interacting with them.
That's really the
end of the talk.
And we want to open it
up now for questions,
as well as invite
you to come talk
to us either after this talk,
as well as at the reception
this evening.
We do have people
here all week as well
at KubeCon, in the
Community Lounge,
as well as in the booth.
Thank you, everyone.
[APPLAUSE]